and probably did what men tend to do
with single mother divorce days which is
pass them on to the next sorry guys this
is how men think and you can shoot the
messenger but guys I interview thousands
of men they typically think that
divorcees are for fun only they don't
see them as a long-term option and the
data supports this most single mothers
never Remar ever most can't even get a
guy to live with them again that is the
future this woman is asking for 20K a
month to raise a child what on Earth do
you need 20K a month for I bet he would
be fine with two grand that should cover
all expenses even three I bet you he
would even do five that that can get you
a one bedroom apartment and pretty much
any major city and I and I even think
that's a bit extreme